[Music]
hey who turned out the Stars hello
seriously where did they go is this the
end of the universe are we all about to
get wiped out this is what if and here's
what would happen if all the stars in
the universe exploded at the same time
for every galaxy that's visible from
Earth there are nine smaller ones that
we can't see even with all the
technology we've developed that's 90% of
all space stuff in the observable
universe that we're missing out on we
can't even see all the stars in the
Milky Way our home galaxy is just too
cluttered with gas dust smaller stars
and well one supermassive black hole all
that makes it impossible to tell how
many stars there really are out there
but whatever that number is it sure has
a lot of zeroes in it watching them
explode all at once might mean that the
earth is about to become nothing more
than dust in space but there's also a
scenario in which we could make it out
alive all stars eventually exhaust their
nuclear fuel and die
some of them depart modestly first
swelling to the stage of a red giant and
then slowly cooling down over billions
of years more massive stars explode into
a blinding bursts of light known as a
supernova as stars go supernova they
spit out a superheated shockwave in all
directions along with a lot of radiation
to supernova exploding 30 light-years
away from Earth could send us so much
radiation that it would start ripping
apart our ozone layer once the ozone
layer was damaged enough to allow just
10% more UV rays to hit the planet's
surface
nearly all marine life would be wiped
out
with 2/3 of the ozone layer gone people
living in mid-latitude cities from
London to Melbourne would start getting
severe sunburns not even SPF 1000 would
save your skin from that much radiation
some stars would take it a step further
they collapsed to form black holes from
earth this would appear as a lot of
bright flashes in the sky because of the
huge distances involved the explosions
would happen in slow motion you could
see one star exploding for over 10 years
as the light from it continued to travel
towards Earth you wouldn't hear any
explosions sound waves need molecules to
travel through since space is a vacuum
there'd be no volume only a really cool
light show with the earth survived these
cosmic fireworks technically it's
possible our planet's surface would be
wiped out and all the oceans would boil
away any survivors would be forced
underground watching out for further
damage from exploding stars but at least
life on Earth could have a chance wait
am I forgetting something all right
we'd be sharing our neighborhood with
one exploding star if the Sun were to go
supernova all life on Earth would
definitely come to an end
the surface of our planet would become
15 times hotter than the surface of the
Sun right now that alone would vaporize
earth within a few days lucky for us the
Sun isn't massive enough to go supernova
but if it exploded it would send matter
in all directions raining down on earth
22 hours after the explosion I'm not
gonna lie to you it would be all bad in
the end
but then exploding stars might form new
stars and new planets orbiting them it
would be the beginning of a new universe
possibly with new habitable worlds and
new life-forms but that's a story for
another what if